albert breer senior nfl reporter and uh
he is the lead content strategist whoa
look at that business card for the mmqb
he joins us on the program albert uh
thank you thanks for joining us here
what did the nfl learn or is trying to
learn from what happened with the
marlins yesterday
i think more than anything else dan it's
going to be what they learned coming out
of this
um you know the expectation for the
league was there's going to be a lot of
positive tests and there were going to
be some opt-outs coming into camp but
we've already seen that
you know i think really the challenge
begins now and so what they're looking
to learn from the other leagues
is when one of these sorts of things
happens what happens after that and so
really
as much of a shock as it was to the
sports world to see the positive tests
with the marlins
i think what the nfl is going to be
studying more so isn't how it happened
it's going to be more how they react how
they're able to contain it
in the aftermath and i think there's
going to be a lot to be learned because
baseball
does have two key similarities to
football number one
they're starting a season they're not
finishing it like basketball and hockey
and number two they're not in a bubble
yeah i'm trying to figure this out as we
move forward
and be optimistic i saw jason lochen iv
from cbs sports he was quoting some
front office executives saying
you know it's not a question of uh if
but when
uh you know this gets shut down or are
we gonna have an eight game schedule are
we gonna have 10
12 game there's no way we're going to
have a full season here these are people
in the business
who are who are having these doubts
but the nfl home office has been quite
kind of quiet
on what the protocol is going to be
peter king had the uh
you know the minnesota vikings story
about everything they're going through
what is the league's approach here of
saying
let's be quiet on all of this and just
kind of plow forward
i mean i'll give you a story from it's
about three four weeks ago
you know somebody pretty high up at the
league office
you know basically said i'm not sure
we've done enough to message this
and because they plowed forward like you
said and kind of
been business as usual and because it
worked for free agency
in the draft maybe it gave them a little
bit of a false sense of security
you know really i think there was this
concern within the league office that
they hadn't messaged enough that there
are going to be problems
and so when we do see dante hightower
opting out
when we do see a list of 12 or 18
rookies every day coming out
but positive covid tests it's a little
bit of a shock to the system and i know
there were some people in the league
office
who felt like they should have done a
better job messaging that and getting it
out like we're expecting this
part of the deal and playing in 2020 and
so i think that's a big part of it
as for the team at the team level i
think one of the things that they're
looking for from the league office right
now
is some more clarity of what happens
post outbreak
and one of the key questions i got i
think it's a really interesting one dan
from some teams yesterday
they still haven't set a number as far
as what constitutes
an outbreak and what it would take to
shut a team down for a week what it
would take
to cause a forfeiture that's something i
think a lot of teams are still looking
for the answer to
is it 15 is it 20 like how many cases
inside a building
will it take for the league to make a
phone call and say you guys got to shut
it down
these are some of the things that lee
still hasn't really clarified to its
teams
when it comes to you know how things are
going to play out over the next few
weeks and
of course more importantly once we get
into the season i was wondering about
this we're talking albert breer
of the mmqb.com and we were talking
about this prior to the start of the
show baseball has done this this
regionalized scheduling do you think
that the nfl
has given thought to let's say the
patriots
the jets the giants and
who else you want to throw in there on
the east coast uh
buffalo buffalo bills are in there uh
florida you have the florida teams so
they're they're able to play each other
twice so those are that's eight games
you have
the of the season you know um but i i
know it throws the schedule off and we
love marquee match-ups but
i don't know if that's a have you
thought about it last ditch
that we keep down our travel down and
you know the home and away is not very
far either home or away
well they had discussed dan and this is
in the spring in the
in april and may the idea of bubble
concept
and and i don't think it would work in
the nfl
to have one big bubble it's just too
many people and so one of the things
that i know it's sort of been tossed
around was
like almost like a pod format like
olympic style group play
and that was something that was shot
down pretty quickly and never advanced
very far for two reasons number one
dr alan sills the league's chief medical
officer didn't think it was a good idea
and number two the players were
wholeheartedly against it and so that
never really got off the ground i think
logistically with football
and you know this like the amount of
players that are shuttled on and off
rosters because the injury rate in the
nfl
would make containing a bubble really
really really logistically different
difficult and so you go back to april
and may and this was something that was
discussed but it never really got off
the ground because
there were some key figures that were
really really against the idea i know we
love to give grades
somebody has to win somebody has to lose
if it's a draft pick you have the trade
with jamal adams
you know the jets sending him for a
couple of first-round draft picks
uh what's your sense with people you've
spoken to
on i i like what seattle did it's
you know the nfl is about now you know
winning now and you have this
opportunity with russell wilson
the jets aren't winning now but uh if
you're giving out grades or who won who
lost
uh where do you stand with this i mean i
like i hate to cut
like it sounds like a cop out saying
win-win but i mean they're two teams in
ver two very different situations i mean
i think joe douglas when he was hired
about a year ago
came to the realization they were a few
drafts away from really contending
um and it was a pretty massive rebuild
he was going to go through and if this
players made it clear to you if jamal
adams has made it clear to you
he's not signing a long-term deal you
have to ask yourself the question
when i get good is he even going to be
here anymore and so i think that that
was part of the equation for the jest
they weren't going to give them away
you know but you know you do want to get
the proper return for them and i think
they were comfortable going forward with
them
really this has been discussed between
the seahawks and the jets for about a
month and a half
and the parameters were in place i'd say
about a week ago and really for the
seahawks to be comfortable with it they
wanted to see the rules
so for the jets this is about restocking
the cupboard and building going forward
for the seahawks look the last piece to
rebuilding a secondary that once had
camp chancellor earl thomas and richard
sherman they got a lot of young players
they liked there
he's an alpha he's a fit for pete
carroll's program
and really right now they feel like
they're close enough and they view these
draft picks as chips and
they didn't think they'd have a chance
to get a player like a jamal adams in
the draft because of where they're
drafting every year
and so is it a calculated risk sure it
is but john schneider's never
never had a problem taking those some of
them have worked out dwayne brown is an
example of that
some of them haven't percy harvin's
another example of that but
certainly i think this is an example of
two teams in very very different
positions yeah i agree with you i said
it's a win-win i don't like giving out
this grade because
the jets grade is fluid that'll be when
let's see what they do in the draft now
you have a new gm there so maybe he
doesn't screw it up like the other gm's
did with all their draft picks
and nobody's there except for sam
darnold and with the jets and you get a
guy who didn't want to be
with the jets uh the the seahawks get
adams uh and you so he's your back end
he's your russell wilson with the
defense there with bobby wagner so
i get it i got the feeling that they
made this move and basically said to
jamal adams
uh you're going to be responsible for
raheem mostert
and george kittle like we're bringing
you in
to make sure you do damage to the san
francisco 49ers because if we get past
them
then we think we'll be the team to beat
or one of the teams to be
going to the super bowl and they felt
like really like he was a smaller
version of cam chancellor in a lot of
different ways like he's more versatile
than
chancellor he's the sort of presence
physically the chancellor was
and like you said i i think if you look
at the seahawks problems the last few
years
they have related to having trouble
covering tight ends so it's george
kittle
it's tyler higby with the rams like this
has been a problem for them and so
it shores up a lot of issues for them
and their on field standpoint but the
off-field stuff i think is important too
like i said like i think such a big part
of who they were
when they were really great in the
secondary was having those alphas in the
secondary
and this really gives them a guy that
kind of brings together that young group
and may give that young group an edge
they really like shaquille griffin they
really like trey flowers
they really like marquis blair the kid
they drafted out of utah a year ago
um they've got quandary digs from the
lions and they really feel like bringing
in a guy like adams
is going to bring him that sort of edge
and attitude that they had when they
were winning
um at a very high level albert thanks
for joining us we appreciate it and uh
we'll continue to read great stuff with
the mmqb all right thanks dan
albert brier senior nfl reporter there
for the mmqb